I want to thank Barnes and Noble for
having me tonight
and I also want to thank c-span for
liking the book enough to want to film
it for book TV which I think will air
later later on this year but mostly I
want to thank all of you for coming for
your interest in the book and for your
interest in Enron it's kind of a special
place special Barnes & Noble for me even
though it wasn't built when I grew up in
Sugar Land but I did grow up here and I
am as Kathleen mentioned a graduate of
delos high school and I'm actually
honored to have some of my high school
teachers here and I thank them very much
for their inspiration but also a growing
up in Houston and knowing you know
knowing the area and knowing the people
I really had a connection to Enron long
before I ever made a decision to go work
there I also went to business school in
Texas which which meant that you know as
a business school student you know a
dream of working for the best companies
and the best company really was Enron
they recruited heavily at UT any MBA
coming out of Texas the choice was Wall
Street a Wall Street firm or Enron
because Enron had that Wall Street feel
to it and it meant a lot to land a job
with the crookedy so for me my NY
experience begins long before I went to
work there I dreamed about Enron
this is the place I really wanted to
work so it's going back to that to that
point to Business School people told me
a lot of different things and I knew
people that work there are new people
that worked with Enron they told me
different things and a lot of people
warned me that Enron is a very very
tough place for anyone to work they
talked about the rank and yank
peer review process which we've all
heard a lot about and I'll get to later
we heard about how Enron was very very
tough to do business with
and tough to compete with and when uh
when things kind of settled out for me
as a business school student the
decision was to actually go to an Enron
competitor so after business school I
found myself competing with Enron and it
was interesting because I quickly
learned Enron's nickname as the Death
Star a lot of people ask about that and
they're interested in that it's really
quite fascinating that all the Star Wars
analogies were drawn to Enron we had Ken
Lay who was known as the Emperor
skilling who became known as Darth Vader
anyone working for Enron was a Jedi and
we later learned in the news following
the collapse that Enron had a lot more
deeper connections to Star Wars than we
thought some of these partnerships were
called Jedi and Chuco obi-wan was
another one also Enron sponsored a
exhibit at the Museum of Fine Arts and
that exhibit was Star Wars magic and
death and so I actually later on one day
I arrived at Enron to see Darth Vader
and some stormtroopers in the lobby
greeting me as a promotion for this
exhibit so the Star Wars thing was
something I knew about before Enron but
but here's the interesting thing I I
went to Enron thinking that was really
cool you know I really thought that
going over to the dark side as people
would say to me was really really neat
and it was kind of interesting so anyway
I'll get back to that but basically I
went from that competitor to a dot-com
that that competitor by the way didn't
do so well mostly because of them Ron
because they couldn't compete then I
went to a dot-com so we know what
happened there and then I went to Enron
so those three I call them the three
strikes those three strikes after Enron
led me to change past a little bit and
I've decided
that I'm gonna put my unbe with MBA away
in the closet for a little bit take a
break from corporate America and try
writing tried writing bad and wrong and
I'm working on another book and and
hopefully this is a direction I can
continue in but back to the Enron story
since my dream of becoming enough next
Jeff Skilling was put on hold I decided
you know here's a way that I can start
writing tell my my version of the story
which i think is a lot different than
the story that you get in the media or
that you would get from an Enron a
knurled report or that we're gonna get
from all the other Enron books and we
know there's a lot of other books my
story is a personal story
it's very character-driven it's not just
about me it's about people I worked with
people that went through that journey
with me
and it starts with Enron being perfect
to the present day which we all know
where end on is today and I I talked to
maybe a hundred plus Enron employers
when I was developing the story and it
became a really most a research project
at one point and I developed as much as
I could for that for that period of time
and it the book actually spans one year
from the time that that I entered the
Death Star and close to April Fool's Day
at to the time that I was finally shut
out of the Enron computer system and I I
timestamp it so it's chronological that
the timestamps included the stock price
you can kind of follow the direction of
the stock as things are unfolding and
it's it's really a different kind of
story it's it's my take on on enter on
my view of the collapse from the middle
of Enron's biggest trading floor and
that's led to a few things for one the
book sitting here and me doing this book
signing thing and also they're gonna
make a TV movie out of it which
is completely bizarre for some poor
schmuck who got laid off you know from
his middle manager position at Enron
it's been quite amazing so anyway there
there are a lot of Enron books and what
I want to do is is take you through a
few stories a few examples of the book
which will sort of show you why this is
a different book the other books a lot
of a lot of people are trying to write
the legal case or the business case or
they want to show you what was said or
what happened in Ken Lay's office on you
know X Day that X time and those are I'm
looking forward to reading those books
myself but but my book is really you
know what it felt like for all of us to
be sitting there when things were
falling apart and the kegs are rolling
in because we're all about to get fired
I mean it it's really bizarre story and
I want to share it with people so the
first thing I wanna start with is is my
state of mind going into Enron that very
very first day so I'm reading reading
from the first chapter called welcome to
the Death Star with Enron I finally felt
like my days of high risk were over it
was time to get back on track and reap
steady rewards from the dues I had paid
the time and money I put towards getting
an MBA the years of grinding away at
Excel spreadsheets finally I was ready
to sprint down the path to my success I
had just hit the jackpot in the form of
a safe secure job the seventh biggest
company in America my fat head and I
walked up the steps to Enron Center
North 50 stories of mirrored glass in a
shape not unlike a speed stick deodorant
container the mirrored glass was part of
the plan we could all Colinas to see how
smart and successful we were as we
entered our building and so there I was
I mean everything about Enron was was
crystal clear it was shiny it was sexy
it was sleek it was chrome it was glass
it was marble it was everything you
dreamed of and just walking into that
Lobby the first thing I noticed is a
huge banner in the lobby stating in
Ron's new corporate mission
was to become the world's leading
company period that was it there was no
world I mean it was the world's leading
energy company but that was no longer
enough now we're off to become the
world's leading company and at fortune
number seven it wasn't that far away and
the way revenues were projected it
looked like Enron would actually be
fortune number one at some point and
that was just amazing to me I mean I've
truly hit the jackpot this is a career
in nirvana and and I was very very
excited and just a few pages later I
meet with my boss on the very first day
and he says to me there was a slight
mix-up in the hiring process and my
response was this is a joke right he
said no and he says it's no big deal
we're going to keep you I just wanted
you to know because some people aren't
real happy that you're here and he later
goes on to tell me that I should just
think of it like I'm adopted so there
was you know that first day the first
sign and there's a lot of signs believe
me throughout this story that that I
missed and everyone knows that Enron was
not perfect this was not a perfect place
and at some point you know I got over
that first day at some point I got into
the job and got more focused on what my
group was doing and put that behind me
and realized okay they're gonna keep me
at least until the next review so anyway
my group the group I was in is a another
interesting point about the book I was
in a group that was a new startup group
and run had a lot of new startup groups
my group was selling bankruptcy
protection which a lot of people think
is kind of interesting here's the
company that is commoditizing everything
you look across this trading floor that
I work on and you see signs for coal for
steel for recycled newsprint you see
Enron online you see
these different new markets and it was
it was Skilling's concept of building
these new markets and Enron but dominate
them and the Empire would just take over
whatever that new commodity was and the
group I was in was trying to commoditize
bankruptcy risk you know I won't put
anyone to sleep explaining the financial
products that we were building but
basically companies that were concerned
about bankruptcy of other companies that
owed the money could buy protection from
us and it was in the form of a swap or
some other financial arrangement to
where Enron would would cover them if
that other company went bankrupt okay so
hold that thought for a while now I want
to take you to the trading floor and the
trading floor if you can imagine this
was 30-foot ceilings
it was dry-erase walls you could ride on
the walls write your ideas on the walls
it was all wide-open we all sat next to
each other it was me next to an
administrative assistant next to a VP
next to the director everyone was mixed
together in very very tight spaces we
had about two square feet of desk space
we had six computer monitors we had a
phone with 450 lines we had ten temps
around ten a hundred of these
flat-screen plasma monitors which are
about you had ten thousand a piece
hanging from the ceilings and this was
to me I mean I've seen pictures of
Mission Control and NASA and that's
nothing I mean this was unbelievable to
me and one day I like to talk about is
the day that first first quarter
earnings came out in 2001 as much the
first time I had witnessed an earnings
report wall at Enron and if you've ever
listened to company conference calls you
know that it's it's the leadership of
the company talking about the results of
the previous quarter and this was on
April 17th 2001
and run stock is at $60 and there's an
echo across the trading floor because
everyone is dialed in to the conference
call that's being broadcast the news
media it's breaking on those flat-screen
TVs and everyone's kind of stopped
working and we're focused on this this
moment when scaling and lie and you know
whoever speaking for Enron starts giving
the details of how many billions we
earned and how much growth that is from
the previous quarter and so on so this
is a big moment for Enron and then
Richard Grubman comes it comes in to ask
questions there's there's a call
literally where analysts can ask
questions of Enron leadership Grubman
then switched from asking a question
about the balance sheet to making a
statement about it you're the only
financial institution that can't come up
with a balance sheet or cash flow
statement after earnings skilling
responded this is CEO skilling skilling
responded well thank you very much we
appreciate that eight whole he didn't
say a whole no but that moment right
there sent shockwaves across the trading
floor mouths dropping home you know
people spilling their coffee I mean it
was amazing people were blown away by
that moment and how it happened well for
me it was a little bit more interesting
because I have a friend who was a
character in the book called Bernie
pickers and Bernie's a good friend of
mine who was covering Enron as an
analyst in the energy industry and
Bernie was actually lined up to take the
next question on the call so he was a
bit concerned but in the end everyone
kind of make made a joke out out of this
thing and and I thought that was a
little strange the news media is going
nuts about him using this word and
calling someone this name on a
conference call went internally and on
Wall Street it kind of became a joke and
part of that joke was an email sent to
me
by my friend Bernie which was an Enron
logo modified to we're no longer said
Enron it said da word which I thought
okay this is great and I was about to
delete it before my boss looking over my
shoulder you know because it's all open
right it saw it started laughing and
asked me to forward it to him now at
that moment I'm making decision is this
something I know my name is attached to
it do I want to forward it to my boss to
what do I want to delete it well it was
clear that people were taking this kind
of lightly and his kinda joke
so I decided okay I'll go ahead forward
it to him and subsequently he Ford it to
his boss and his boss boarded his boss
and I write about in the book what
actually ended up happening with that
email but months after finishing anatomy
of greed I actually talked to a New York
Times reporter who confirmed to me that
in fact all of the Enron leadership had
seen the emails seen the logo and got an
incredible kick out of it and thought of
this hysterical so that was one of the
amusing anecdotes from from that
conference call I want to take you a few
months later into August and things that
Enron have been running pretty smoothly
the stocks now down to $43 which is a
quite a drop but still $43 is a pretty
good shape that day August 14th was the
day that skilling resigned and the the
day started actually with an email from
Tenley and Jeff Skilling and I have the
emails actually here in the book but but
one of the emails came in the morning
and said you know we're looking forward
to this afternoon's employee meeting and
so on and it was signs we look forward
to seeing you there Ken and Jeff things
couldn't been more perfect at Enron at
that moment seven hours later an email
from Ken Lay is with regret that I have
to announce that Jeff Skilling is
leading
enron that was a rollercoaster ride that
day his email later goes on to say that
I'm pleased to say that he's agreed to
enter into a consulting arrangement with
a company to advise me and the board of
directors so we're kind of getting a
mixed message he's leading Enron he's
gonna stay on to consult why is he
leaving the debate went back and forth
and internally we knew that you know his
response to the media that it was he was
leading for personal reasons we knew
that there had to be something more to
it this is this is a man who's at the
top of his game
he's a genius he created Enron he
created all these new markets he's
winning awards for how brilliant is but
clearly with going back to the the
name-calling incident in the first
quarter and a few other things that I
discussed in the book different quotes
and different things that happen with
skilling clearly he was here's a bit
uncomfortable with being CEO of Enron
and that's that's the message that we
got internally and it was it was an
amazing day just that that day we found
out he was leaving was an incredible
shock but looking back on things now I
look at that same email from Ken Lay
it's on page 91 if you have the book he
says in the second half now it's time to
look forward I want to assure you that I
have never felt better about the
prospects for the company our
performance has never been stronger our
business model has never been more
robust our growth has never been more
certain people go back to that that
August 14th email and say that that
that's the moment that has gotten Ken
Lay and a lot of people in a lot of
trouble because everything we know about
Enron now seems to me that you know
August mid August or before people
should have sensed people who are
involved in these transactions knew
about the debt knew about the things
that were building knew about the house
of cards could have at that point
started to come clean and maybe
guided the media and guided Wall Street
along a you know it would have been an
ugly road but it would have been a path
that would have kept in run along and
and round Enron a law around for a very
long time but that decision clearly you
know wasn't made it was time to start
spinning things and and I've got to tell
you from where I was sitting in the
middle that trading floor this the spin
was spinning faster than you can imagine
it was it was nuts and it was day in and
day out from that moment forward Enron
preaching to the world that the company
is OK things are perfect things have
never been better you know 10 years out
20 years out this is the future these
new markets innovation it was it was
drilled into our heads and to the
investors Minds
that nothing was wrong from from that
moment forward so that that's why that
chapter is called the beginning at the
end and that to me was the the biggest
turning point in the story another sign
I mean I talk about signs that things
weren't weren't well with Enron Maya my
group and a few my colleagues were
headed out to California to attend a
conference where we would talk about our
business in the business of bankruptcy
protection and instead of really
focusing on what we were gonna be doing
at the conference how we would present
ourselves things that we would try to
get across to the media into to
customers we had a meeting with Enron PR
about how to deal with angry California
people and this is this is early October
this is when it stocks in the mid 20s
the story was that scaling was in
California and he had a pie thrown in
his face the California Attorney General
had made some very harsh comments about
wishing the Ken Lay would end up in
prison with a roommate named spike so
these things were happening in
California and we're about to hit out
there
and pitch our business and you know here
we are we're not talking about our
business we're meeting with Enron PR to
talk about you know the concern
so here's PR talking to me don't worry
about pies
they saved those pies for extremely
high-profile high-profile targets that
same group that hits killing also hit
Bill Gates I said okay so I crossed pie
anxiety off my list if anyone starts
going off on you about Enron's role in
California energy crisis just refer them
to our department okay so that that was
a sign to me that the Enron PR machine
was priority number one and and to this
day I talked about when people ask what
we really went wrong at Enron it was it
was about the hype it was about the
perception it was a company that focused
our shifted their focus from real
day-to-day operations making money
making the right deals negating their
own risk shifted from that to spinning
perception and pumping up the stock and
the reason it shifted is because there
was a huge reward for pumping up the
stock when executives and even myself
have stock options there's there's a
short term gain right there every every
quarter for a higher stock price and you
know 10 20 years out which is really how
stocks should be valued that wasn't the
issue it was quarter to quarter how are
we gonna meet that earnings target
because Wall Street will punish you if
you come up a penny short and it reached
a point where it was everything anyone
could do inside Enron to make that extra
penny and when we look now at the people
being indicted and the people pleading
guilty and everything that's going to
come out of this we're looking at deals
and financial arrangements that were
aimed at getting that penny meeting that
earnings expectation and that sort of
that's how Enron spun out of control but
that's just my opinion
so things got ugly
and they got especially ugly in
mid-october the third quarter earnings
report Enron didn't make that target
because they had a billion dollar loss
and the billion dollar loss it's very
confusing they in fact when the story
broke when they when they have the
earnings report they actually reported
it as a huge gain you know we made you
know four hundred thousand four hundred
billion dollars or whatever we made by
the way we lost a billion dollars but
that's non-recurring that's unusual so
it shouldn't count and it was kind of an
afterthought and it was amazing that
even then that moment at that moment
when we've lost a billion dollars or the
net I think was six hundred million or
whatever it was at that moment they're
still trying to spin positive so anyway
that was mid-october and things start
falling apart rather quickly and the day
to day the things we've all read The
Wall Street Journal the different news
events about fast now and the
partnerships and whatnot those things
sent Enron into a downward spiral and
stock which was in the mid-20s in early
October was quickly headed into the
teens and lower and here's the day I
want to a moment I want to share with
you it's actually October 24th the stock
is in the teens and this is the point
that I'm at personally knowing that the
company is running out of money things
are falling apart we're all about to get
canned McClane he's my boss I spun
around to mcleaney hey Greg you got a
second he spun around to me sure what's
up
we're spinning around because we sit
back to back and if we lean back we hit
our heads he spun around to me sure
what's up
he looked beaten up I guess we all
looked beaten up I don't know how to ask
this in fact I'm not sure how this works
I paused to make extra sure I said it
right is it possible you can get me laid
off like soon
I couldn't believe I was asking my own
boss to get rid of me to my surprise he
laughed I wish I could in fact I wish we
could all get laid off it's just not up
to us and run basically has a hold on
all personnel changes until things
settle down now the reason you why would
I ask my boss to lay me off the reason
is because we knew Enron was running out
of money and if you're if you're knowing
in knowing how tough the job market was
and if you know that it's just a matter
of time the best thing you can hope for
is a severance package and in the these
days when you know thousands of people
are getting laid off from every company
it's very important that the company
actually have money in the bank to tell
you that severance package and as it
turns out reality set in when we did get
laid off there were no severance
packages a lot of money was spent
retaining employees people who got to
keep their jobs but we were laid off and
we weren't at least that first day we
weren't given anything now some battles
have been fought since then to pay us
but at the time you know things were so
bad that I was spinning around to my
boss to ask him to fire me so that
that's sort of the that's a long way
from you know I Fathead walking up to
the to the Deathstar for the first time
and another part of this book which is
very interesting right when I went to
write actually write this book there
were a lot of people I knew at Enron
that I didn't work with on a day-to-day
basis they were very senior people some
executives and they were very helpful
and and gave me a lot of information
about Enron some of it extremely
sensitive and for that reason because it
was extremely sensitive information I
made a decision in writing the book to
disguise some people for one it was the
condition by which they agreed to talk
to me for another reason I just didn't
feel like it was right to thrust them
into the spotlight and subject subject
them to
and questions from the media and whatnot
and so this this character the character
in the book I call him mr. blue and mr.
blue incidentally in the movie will be
played by Brian Dennehy I so so imagine
Brian Dennehy as I'm reading you this
conversation this piece of conversation
with mr. blue he leaned in there was an
unwritten rule a rule of no bad news if
I came to them with bad news it would
only hurt my career my response bad news
about what about Enron's deals how
little since they made how they would
lose money how they were run by
unqualified egomaniacs the waitress
brought him another glass I wondered if
he got some sort of frequent flier
discount on the good stuff
these guys were ex-military X Harvard X
whatever Ken Lay was looking for they
were brilliant people and somewhere they
fit the strategy but on a project to
build a billion-dollar power plant he
needed someone who knew how to build a
billion-dollar power plant you're
talking about India he sat back and
looked up I'm talking about India
Guatemala Puerto Rico the Dominican
Republic Brazil the Philippines I'm
talking about the globalization of
stupidity I'm talking about Enron
executives jetting around the world
pissing off foreign governments and
destroying people's lives he was
starting to get angry about five dollars
worth of blue labels slashed out of his
glass all in the name of someone's blank
bonus I snacked quietly he wiped his
forehead he adjusted his position in the
chair and got more comfortable he was
just getting started
like that conversation I mean was really
looking back on it was really a therapy
session and these are a lot of people
lost so much and and that's another
point I want to get to is is I really am
one of the lucky ones I wasn't there
that long I didn't lose that much I lost
my job my career was sidetracked I lost
a few thousand dollars in Enron stock
but really nothing compared to to people
like mr. blue
do you know countless others that we've
read about who lost their life savings
and again you know I can't I can't say
enough I'm at how lucky I feel that I
didn't join Enron say ten years ago
because that day we got laid off it was
it was amazing it was well first of all
the bankruptcy group was getting phone
calls from people wanting to know how
they could buy protection on Enron going
bankrupt the the kegs rolled in
it turned into a farewell party there
was no work to be done as soon as Enron
got a credit downgrade our business shut
down we could no longer do business the
trading stopped the phone stopped
ringing
people were miserable and people were
updating the resumes and it turned into
almost a goodbye party and I mentioned
the kegs and that's a lot of people
asked you know it was this a fraternity
atmosphere well the trading floor was
there are a lot of different parts to
Enron the trading floor really was that
fraternity like atmosphere with football
flying footballs flying and you know you
know bad jokes things like that things I
read about in the book but can't say
here is an interesting place but but
that day that that last day it really
hit home
we were addressed in mass they they
talked to you know groups of 3200
employees at a time saying you're all
laid off you have 30 minutes to get out
of the building now again for me it
didn't take much time for me to throw my
short career into a cardboard box but
four people had been here 10 years in 30
minutes not even a one-on-one
conversation with an HR representative
or or some some assistance in the future
maybe even the severance package now 30
minutes to go the building and it was a
circus we walked out with our cardboard
boxes the cameras that we had been
watching what they were filming on the
screens above us
months now those cameras were on us
walking out and it was an amazing day
and it was very emotional and it was it
was interesting and I talked a lot about
the different reactions very split down
the middle some people tried to make a
joke out of it some people were in tears
and anyway that was a horrible day for
Enron and and for me the story didn't
end one of the post layoff events for me
that I talk about in the book I got left
on the payroll and this is a it was a
mistake not unlike the mistake of hiring
me a mistake that actually has funded
the writing of this book I really was in
a position where I needed to go find my
next job and my next job was gonna be in
consulting or another energy company
down the street but because of this
mistake and it wasn't just me it was
tons of other people I knew at Enron
they accidentally left us on the payroll
and without that there's no way I could
have attempted the writing of this book
and some other interesting things happen
that I talked about in here I had a
co-worker he tried out for the women at
then Ron Playboy issue she didn't make
it
everyone tried to sell their Enron
materials on eBay I made a few dollars
off mouse pads and golf tees and things
like that and I actually tried to sell
some Enron emails which landed me a
story in the New York Times and I a lot
of other things happened that I won't go
into but what really what happened to me
personally was I realized that it was
time to try something different the
corporate world again the three-strikes
the corporate world had a kind of a sour
taste in my mouth
I'd learned some hard lessons and I had
a story to tell about Enron
and you know the reporter who with the
New York Times who put the story about
the eBay incident and there's actually a
picture of the the article in here he
and I talked quite a bit and I found
that you know from my words to the front
pages and New York Times I realized
people are really interested in what
happened at Enron it's amazing and even
even today a year after this thing
started the media is still all over the
inrun thing and I think it's gonna
continue for many many years I mean we
it's kind of like Law & Order right we
have the the first part which is what
happened and finding out the truth of
everything and the second part is the
courtroom drama and you know we've got
years and you know many more books to be
written about that but I realized at
some point that this was something that
had value and Enron was paying me so I
decided to write a book and it's been a
crazy experience and and not just the
book but getting whisked out to
Hollywood for meetings with producers
and turning this thing into a movie and
it again it shows and I think the movie
shows that this book really is a
different kind of book this is not again
it's not the legal case it's not the
business case it's a personal story and
it's myself and the people I worked with
and dozens of other characters the
average Enron employees and what it was
like to live through this experience and
to see this collapse from the inside to
see it from the middle of Enron's
fanciest trading floor but there is
there's good news in the end and that's
another thing I wanted to mention is
we're seeing it now we're seeing the
change in the accounting systems we're
seeing a change in the way Wall Street
does their earnings
quarter-to-quarter and the expectations
we're seeing changes in white-collar
crime legislation we're seeing changes
in the way people invest their money
diversification that's all I can say
especially in your 401k and those
changes there as well there's also a
change in attitude
company leaders and board members these
people now know that they could have a
net they could be sitting on an Enron
and these independent board members who
really are that are the only people
whose interests are aligned with with us
as investors those independent board
members are really the watchdogs for us
because they're the only ones that have
our best interest at heart the long-term
value of the stock and can really keep
an eye on what's happening in the
company and approve or deny things that
are happening on an operational basis
but the really good news is that the
people of Enron are moving on and again
I mentioned a hundred plus people that
I've dealt with in writing this book and
since writing the book I get tons of
email every day from people who either
worked at Enron or we're dependent on
Enron as you know a supplier or a small
business next door and people are really
I'm amazed at how resilient they are and
let's go back a second to Enron hiring
the best and the brightest these are all
brilliant people in the first place
and I've been amazed to see what people
are doing now and not only have they
moved on but a lot of people have like
me stepped away from the corporate world
and they're now doing things like
teaching or they become therapists or
counselors and things like that and it's
amazing to see how people and taking the
Enron experience tucked it away learn
from it and move forward and it's it's
great to see that I want to open it up
for Q&A they've asked that if you have a
question that you step up to the
microphone congratulations I had no idea
you were local I didn't attack them and
I do read the paper but one of my
daughters and I'm going to ask you to
autograph the book for her as a writer
in California and
she was here about a month ago and she
was just you know talking about the
effect of the energy thing out there and
we came in this door matter of fact she
picked up some books I don't know where
were they're yours was here then or not
but she said I ought to read about that
sometime so her birthday's coming up and
she's going to get a book but my
question is what about I mean on a scale
of one to ten what was the impact of
Enron itself on on the California
situation when Ron was was one of many
companies dealing in that market I'm
trying to remember the percentage I'm
thinking is from the low teens the
percentage of that market that Enron was
was actually involved in but inland was
very vocal about deregulation and
deregulation was stamped as the problem
right the problem in California is
deregulation and Enron is the company
not only in Washington DC but across the
country from donating lots of money to
lots of politicians trying to get
deregulation moving and California was
the first market to go there so very
very involved to answer your question in
in creating that legislation very vocal
in skilling was on the front line and he
was out in California and he was
defending Enron and talking about free
market system and how how great it would
would eventually be for Californians
with their utility bills and there was
debate back and forth and you know I've
heard stories about
bogus trades and things and whatnot that
drove up our prices in California and
you know hopefully that stuff will all
come out and we'll find out more about
if anything was done illegally as far as
what was done legally
I really do believe and be happy to
argue with you that the deregulation in
California was done incorrectly it
really wasn't the deregulation that
Enron was fighting for was not the
deregulation that was put in place and I
talked about that in the book as well so
I hate to say it but I'm almost
unschooling aside when it comes to to
California I graduated from Dulles in
1990 and I nearly failed my senior
English class I'm not kidding
mostly because of my unorthodox writing
style the book is great thank you I
don't know how I found out about it but
I got it off Barnes and noble.com
and have already finished it I was in
the process of reading about copper when
it hit the news and you had already said
he would be charged with wire fraud and
the exact same things he was charged
with there are also two real estate
agents that were mentioned in the
newspaper articles as being involved in
as three percent people they contributed
three percent of into one of the
companies either one Raptors or greater
South Hampton yeah or the two coasts so
were those the ones I mean they named
him in the paper were you aware of those
two individuals yeah I forget their
names I don't want to try and guess
we're supposed to withhold judgment
until they're right right they're all
they're all in the Sun and I really do
hope that everyone involved gets due
process and gets fair fair treatment I
mean when I saw the congressional
hearings I know I'm not answering your
question on that I don't know the names
of who is in the papery stuff we're done
maybe okay yeah there are other people
that invested in some of those
partnerships I think that's the South
Hampton they look at their money are you
fast I'll give them that money to invest
for him as far as the powers report
States and as far as the research I did
that was their own money but it was a
few thousand dollars for a return of you
know hundreds and thousands yeah it's a
return we put all dream of getting thank
you thank you very much
anyone else can you tell us more about
the movie can I tell you more about the
way I can tell you that they are making
a Hollywood version of my book which
it's there's a lot more focus on the
relationships and the people and for
example my wife really isn't a big part
of the book but in the movie she'll be
played by Shannon Elizabeth from
American Pie and it's you know so
Hollywood put their spin on my book and
it'll be an entertaining movie the
writer the person who adapted my book
into a screenplay isn't even name is
Steve Mazur he wrote liar liar
Heartbreakers and little rascals so put
those three names together and the the
other actors I mentioned Brian Dennehy
we also have Mike Farrell from mash and
provenance he'll be playing ten lay and
a young actor named Christian Kane who's
sort of a rising star he'll be playing
me it's very interesting that they've
told me I'm gonna get a cameo we'll see
how that goes probably a cafeteria
worker or maybe I'll stand in the back
of an elevator or something but they're
filming they're actually filming it in
Canada they built an Enron trading floor
up there I've been reviewing the
screenplay for the Enron elements
reviewing the accuracy the Enron parts
of the screenplay but other than that
it's kinda out of my hands I don't even
know when it's going to be aired but it
will it will be on CBS
can you play yourself imma stick to
writing I know about acting thank you
very much any other questions
you may join tara lipinski is putting
sugar land on them i'm dan thank you